Addison wrote in saying do you guys make
your own coffee at home or prefer to buy
it this may be someone who's never
watched or listened to the program
before because there's a lot wrapped up
in this question but I I have I
typically make my coffee at home we have
two david pakman show coffee blends
available at david pakman.com slash gear
one for espresso machines one for
traditional actually that it's wrong to
even say that I know people say David in
most of the world traditional coffee
machines are espresso machines drip
coffee machines is what I mean and
typically I'll make my own coffee but I
often have meetings at coffee shops or
whatever I do not go to chain coffee
shops with some very specific exceptions
but absolutely no Starbucks no Dunkin
Donuts no Panera
no Pete's no uh you know even Barrington
Coffee Roasters which is one here in
Boston I will not go to I try to go to
local coffee shops but you know over
time I feel like the coffee I make at
home is better than what I get out
except at really good coffee shops see
under advice of counsel I'm going to
invoke my Fifth Amendment right against
self-incrimination yeah and decline to
answer this topic all right that's fair
and I think if you google Pat Keurig
you'll figure out a lot of what what is
behind Pat's recusal I'm moving in the
right direction though I'm actually
considering getting a drip coffee
appliance that's just meant to brew one
or two cups at a time oh yeah yeah you
can do that I mean if you get a minicam
X or even a small French press that's
basically a cup and a half all right and
I'm honestly not against going to Dunkin
Donuts or Starbucks whenever if you're
out and about you just can't really do
it every day because if you're spending
$3 on coffee every day sound like much
but that adds up to a thousand dollars
over the course of the year yes and
there's a lot of different personal
finance articles that tackle that exact
issue much to the dismay of I don't know
a lot of other people who sort of
disagree with the entire lot a
millionaire anyway I'm sort of going in
another direction here but in any case
Addison I do make my own coffee at home
but if I go to a non chain coffee shop I
will get it my drink of choices is
basically cappuccino that's typically
what I have or espresso macchiato
that that's the way I go I drink very
little drip coffee at this point now
vegan Pat of course is relegated to the
depths of a weak drip coffee because you
can't really make cappuccino without
milk no although black coffee is the
best type of coffee and also I have to
ask would you ever be willing to have
convenience-store coffee like at a
7-eleven or at a desk ease or is that
just below you no it's not that it's
below me think it's good thanks for
setting me up for that but it's I know
you have a leadest coffee habit it's not
that it's below me it's that the only
reason I would ever be restricted to
only a 7/11 for coffee is because it's a
time of day where there are no coffee
shops open and I don't drink coffee at
those times of day I think my lawyers
are going to be very upset with me for
speaking so openly about this topic yeah
no I don't think it's going to be good
okay
that's it Addison lastly this is going
to be I think a very very short one